(slow string music)
- Alright, another lunch by myself.
Ah, damn. I was gonna
catch up on Instagram.
Is this seat taken?
- All you.
- Oh, it'll be fine. Maybe
I can still scroll through.
Nope. She's looking at me.
Ok, um...
So how's it going?
- Good.
- Ah, that's all you got? Come on, Elliot.
You've read books on this.
- Traffic, right? Terrible this morning.
- No, it was pretty good for me.
Good for me? That doesn't even make sense!
Did I hit a leprechaun on
the way to work or something?
- Did you watch Game
of Thrones last night?
- Oh, no, I don't get HBO.
But I did see Antiques Roadshow.
You know what's more amazing than dragons?
An extremely rare Navajo chief's blanket
worth half a million dollars.
Yeah, find one of those
on Game of Thrones!
(lettuce crunches)
Oh that's, she's really
plowing through that salad.
Good salad, huh?
Instagram, here I come!
- Well, back to the grind.
- Yeah. Go get 'em, tiger.
"Go get 'em, tiger."? What?
I've never set that
before in my entire life.
But it was worth it. Alone at last.
Eating alone is the absolute best.
I think she called me Ethan the other day.
It's Elliot.
Elliot.
(deep inspiring music)